when it comes down to business planning
for following your there's three
different types of people there are
those that are not prepared there are
those that are winging it maybe they'll
spend a couple hours with their friends
just kind of putting something together
and then there are those that are
absolutely prepared excited cannot wait
to execute their game plan today I'm
going to talk to you about how you can
be prepared for 2020 so let's get right
into it before I do business planning
for following your I gotta get my mind
in the right state let me explain what I
mean to you so one I have a calendar out
to I recap 2019 I look I look at
potential 2020 threats I may have then
things to anticipate numbers to measure
topics to follow people to follow in
2020 that have to do with war I'm at
with my business so let me get through a
couple of different things first of all
recap 2019 so one I study trends what
does that mean I need as many data
points for me as possible
anything sales hires fires lost money
technology anything I can look at with
my months I need I need the good the bad
the ugly we lost one of our best people
you know you had a certain compliance
issue you had an incredible month you
had a great summer but you had a week
fall or he had a great start but you had
a bad I'm looking at all of that good
bad and ugly then I'm measuring 2019 to
2018 in this way January 2019 January
2018 February February March March q1 q1
q2 q2 then I'm doing best month vs. best
month best quarter vs. best quarter I'm
trying to see if my seasons are changing
and if I'm having any other trends then
I measure the initiatives I announced
last year how did this end it should
have work this is how I work what kind
of results we got with this this is the
results we got okay I like this maybe we
need to continue this maybe we need to
change this we had a meeting the other
day for three hours it was about
changing one of the initiatives that
we've been going for the last four years
how can we adjust it to produce better
results so we looked at that next is
obviously missed opportunities by doing
a SWOT analysis
what is our current strengths what are
our weaknesses what opportunities do we
have
you know what threats taking place last
week was a very big Insurance week for
us I'm in the financial industry so
everybody was in town so we were having
very interesting meetings for technology
for speed for compliance for things to
look out for but it's because we recap
what happened in 2019 potential 2020
threats industry is first one regulation
I put couple them here with industry and
regulation but it's pretty much the same
thing what things are changing in your
industry that could affect you you have
to start thinking about it so I'll call
Iran there are a group of five people
I'll call and I'll say hey let's just
call them John hey John anything I need
to be looking out for for 2020 yeah
there's three things that happen is
there anything that's going on the
financial industry need to know about
yeah that's it there's any carry I need
to know about they fill me or not right
because of industry politics on the
politics side with 2020 you don't know
who's gonna get electus you have to ask
yourself if Trump gets elected is it
good for your business versus if
Elizabeth Warren gets elected if there
is an impeachment if there is you have
to put all of those things in place
because politics is going to affect your
business most people don't look at it
that way but it is going to affect your
business economy what could happen in
the economy that's a threat right we're
gonna have some topics to go to here in
a minute
regulation we talked about family health
personal here's what I mean by family
health personal too often like I had a
conversation with one of my guys and he
says what do you think is the reason why
I slowed down I said can I just be
honest with he says Patrick do you know
how it is tell me anything I said you've
put on 35 pounds in 2019 what do you
want me to tell you I mean every time
you're going like this you're trying to
cover your stomach it bothers you you
know you don't feel good you don't like
it and then you go home and you you got
to take care of your health but that has
nothing to do with business it has a lot
to do with business it has a lot to do
with your marriage it has a lot to do
with the way you look at yourself when
you come out of the shower you're
looking at yourself in a mirror and at
the same time you're carrying an
additional 35 pound Dumbo for 12 months
you know how hard it is to do that and
work effectively you're probably shorter
temper you're upset you're annoyed
because your health needs to be looked
at so you got to go get your physicals
done you got to go do bloodwork you got
to go get your body checked out to make
sure you don't have a potential health
2020 threat anticipate expected events
that could come up in 2020 we
invested into technology it's gonna be
ready by August first is it ready are we
on track or the phases coming through
we're hiring the new CEO or are we good
for that we're hiring a new CEO do we
have enough pool of people we're looking
at we're getting ready to introduce this
whole new side of comp
we're getting ready to bring this all of
these company events you have to be
ready for and ask if the right people
are leading it and you're ready for the
deadline so you got to ask everybody are
we on track on this I had a board
meeting last week the entire
conversation was are we on track on how
to hitting these deadlines things to
anticipate in 2020 new hires new
products new comp your next 15 move in
every aspect of your life
my next 15 moves is first I got a call
those six guys I got a recruit that
person I got invested into that
technology but you gotta know your next
15 moves in every area my kid my
daughter was just here right now running
out running out all over the place
three-year-old daughter everything with
her I have my next 15 moves with her
with my boys with my marriage with my
family with my dad with everyone it's
your 15 moves to know what you're doing
next things to anticipate in 2020
numbers to measure every months record a
recorders record and how you feel 2020
which records are going to be broken in
what month in what quarter to lay laid
out on the line right so you're looking
at it then you put 2020 goals here's how
many new subscribers we're gonna have to
our monthly subscription that we offer
for this product with your company
here's how many new employees we're
bringing on board here's how many new
customers here's how much top-line
revenue here's profits all of that stuff
is numbers with goals you got to have
revenue net profits new subscribers that
you may have topics to follow on 2020
that could affect your business trade
war obviously 5g brexit election US Iran
and epstein the reason why I put Epstein
this typically is for me around 20
different topics Epstein I'm giving you
an example I'm not telling you to follow
what's happening with the Epstein
scandal I'm putting it here because of
the recording that came out of this one
guy that's got this project Veritas
going on that some of the ABC executives
were tied to and there were some
powerful entrepreneur CEO billionaires
that are tied to the name with this if
that comes out it affects the economy if
you're in the technology space that
could be a good or bad or an ugly that
could be an operator
could be a threat but you got to follow
closely to know how to move so it's not
a surprise to everybody next people to
follow closely in 2020 you got Trump you
got Elizabeth Warren obvious reasons
Biden obvious reasons
what if Hillary comes out of nowhere
because she's kind of hinting I'm a I
think I can I beat on once I can beat
him again so you got to follow her right
Jared Kushner who is a very very strong
a power player for Trump's team he's
married to his daughter so he comes
across very polished and strong said
that somebody got to watch closely
Bezos mosque Dorsey Zak all of these
guys I got another 15 names because some
of it's my industry but you got to study
which people have followed then it got
calendar okay and I'm calendar this is
very empty this is not how my calendar
is gonna look like because my counter is
gonna be personal it's gonna be business
on a personal side I sit down my wife
and I say which ones I can attend what I
cannot attend so look Christmas I want
to do this great family here's what
we're gonna do crate tell me the
birthdays pop up up up okay tell me
what's going on with the company trips
this company wants us to go to Tokyo
this year I don't know if I can make you
that company wants me to go to Paris we
want to get closer with these guys so
maybe we'll do this that company wants
us to go here baby I don't know if I can
make to all of these trips and then we
got family wedding that's all personal
and you got business and then you have
events that could take place that's not
business or personal is just what is
going on for example I want to know
January 1st falls on a Wednesday the
31st will be on a Tuesday what are we
doing to finish off 2019 solid right
25th is Chinese New Year's why do I have
it in there if I'm in a business tie to
it I want to know how they're
strategizing going into their new year
because China is a very strategic
country especially with the whole thing
that's going on with made in China you
got to kind of watch what they're gonna
be doing number February third Iowa
caucus March third Super Tuesday
primaries right against that's politics
July 6 through the night I'm hosting the
vault conference this will be the second
you were doing it last year was in
Dallas this year's gonna be a Florida I
told everybody in Europe I'm gonna do
East Coast so it's gonna be easier for
Europe and Middle East to show up in
Asia to show up so we're doing in
Florida it's gonna be the largest
conference from south of Orlando to rent
we run out at the biggest place 4,000
people going to show up probably from
120 hundred 30 different
trees last year was 43 different
countries were expecting a very big
meeting yeah you know we'll go through
our three-day event from 9 a.m. to 9
p.m. which is case studies it's very
technical event it's not like one of
those things you go towards like buy
this product buy that products you're
gonna be learning and leaving with
exactly what to do with your CEO you
know executive entrepreneur doesn't
matter that content will be for yourself
you haven't yet registered click on a
link below the vault conference to find
out more about it tickets are moving
fairly quickly but find out more about
that I wouldn't miss the vault
conference in 2020 you got DNC that a
Democratic National Convention xiii to
do the 16th of july in milwaukee
wisconsin we're gonna find out who's
gonna be the candidate and in july 7 to
argus night is the Olympic Summer
Olympics right that's taking place I
believe in Tokyo right it's what's
taking place August 24 to the 27th
Republican National Convention so again
you're watching both of them going back
and forth October 20 2002 BIR 20th of
2020 is Dubai Expo it's when it begins
if you haven't kind of see what's going
on with Dubai X but they're trying to
connect everybody together it's gonna be
pretty interesting they've been
preparing for this since November of
2013 by the way and in November third is
vote new president US 26 Thanksgiving
25th Friday Christmas December falls on
a Friday so again planning so you kind
of see where I'm going with this right
this is just to give you a glimpse like
if people come to me and sit down and I
do business planning with them it's very
much I can probably train on this for a
full day this is not a small topic this
is a big topic I'm just giving you an
idea on how to be thinking about going
into your new year to make sure 2020
becomes the beginning of the greatest
years of your life because you went away
from being the person that's unprepared
you're graduating from being the winging
person that just talks a lot but then
you never look at your business plan
again you're becoming a professional
because you're doing it right and
because you're doing it right it
produces excitement know when you go
into your new year if you execute it
this could be very special year for you
I've got two videos I want you to watch
one of them is a video I did a year ago
titled seven habits to help you dominate
2019 these seven habits also apply to
2020 the other one is as a keynote I
give in Long Beach a few months ago and
the title for this one is thinking like
a grant
entrepreneur a mess
grandmaster entrepreneur if you haven't
watches do so this will kind of give you
a glimpse of what the vault conference
is going to look like for three days
except this is only 45 minutes this
one's going to be three days nine to
nine but a lot of different activities
taking place again if you haven't
register register for the vault click on
a link below in the description to
register if you haven't sub please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care